may the fourth be with you ladies and gentlemen
it is 5 45 in the morning we just got our moon
night episode 6 reaction up and now it's time for
the obi-wan trailer can't wait to see it leave a
like if you can use the force to leave a like and
yeah subscribe and click that notification bell
because you best bet we're gonna be covering this
show right here on the chanel if you haven't seen
our reaction to the first trailer that's also up
here on the channel let's get into action people
they're coming
stay hidden great shot of
him but we will not survive
leave us alone when the time comes he must be
trained like you trained his father who ouch
uncle owen you still want kenobi
he's gone
maybe you've been looking in the wrong places
i want every lowlife and bounty hunter to
squeeze him like john wick yeah absolutely
want but it would be cool you got it you
want to maybe want us to want to want to
see him you know what i mean these are good
trailers man there are shots with the the
river character especially when she's like you
can't run ob1 that straight remind me out of
uh the inquisitor man blink on her name the the
one from uh the jedi fallen order the prologue to
that video game always nice to be reminded of that
video game at any given moment just popping into
my mind right now there's something i believe it
was ryanairy from screen crush that beautiful beat
who pointed this out how there was a line in a new
hope vader says like the last time i felt a tremor
in the force was when he sensed his old master
obviously being obi-wan kenobi the reason i'm
bringing that up is because i've seen you know a
good amount of people because a lot of people are
very much excited to see hayden christiansen don
the suit of darth vader once more and square off
with obi-wan again however i know there was that
other camp that is often like ah wasn't that fight
on mustafar supposed to be their last big fight
doesn't that kind of undermine some of the context
from the moosa fire fight to the new hope fight
he says last night i felt the tremor in the force
in a new hope so that could be in reference to
the fight that is actually going to take place
in this specific series so i'm excited to see
that unfold i'm just i'm just excited to see
you know you and mcgregor return and of course to
see hayden christensen get a second shot because
i feel like more people have come around to him
i remember the backlash that hayden christensen
would get and i feel like a lot more people have
come around to his performance i'm excited to
see if he can you know just get it and get an
opportunity to leave kind of a good impression
for audiences and for himself too to feel that way
walking away from it all i like that they're still
keeping some kind of mystery around how and and
what shape exactly hayden christensen is gonna
show up i like that anticipation factor getting
a couple glimpses of darth vader's suit and the
bionic arm and stuff like that i'm really excited
to see what they make of that because i think
they have an interesting and unique opportunity
here and the fact that you have something that's
both prequel and sequel at the same time you're
filling in a middle chapter that there's certainly
lore for but we haven't seen play out this way
while i could imagine a scenario in which yeah
they have to be very careful in how they perhaps
contextualize that tremor in the force if that's
what they're going to try and do i feel like there
is enough here that they could make something very
meaningful especially the way they're building
this is like a six episode event rather than
just like oh it's another one of our series or
something like that like something about this
feels a little separate and a little more special
in a way from out here and obviously obi-wan is
you know one of the most iconic characters so
i feel like you have that really great sense of
honoring his portrayal of the character and then
yeah giving hayden christiansen the chance to come
back and to put a fresh stamp on it under you know
perhaps some slightly different supervision there
are certain aspects of the prequels that have
been very detrimental to the people involved so
to see him get to have this chance to come back
and really again go toe-to-toe hopefully with
obi-wan even if the whole show isn't necessarily
about that you know that the presence of the two
of them is gonna be really significant together
so that's just something super exciting you know
you've got these sort of cd obviously there's
tons of cyberpunk aesthetic throughout star
wars but these yeah neon lit cities that do have
that john wick vibe to it like it looks like it's
going to be a sort of rough and tumble outlawish
sort of show but something different altogether
than a mandalorian type thing well yeah when i was
saying john wick i meant more in the sense of how
there's going to be more than the inquisitors
going after him it's going to be like all they're
trying to get all the bounty hunters to go
hunt him down specifically so it's getting
that vibe of like john wick chapter two and three
where everyone's going after him and the action
does feel a lot more there's like that handheld
effect it feels more akin to the action that we
kind of got in rogue one but we're gonna get some
lightsaber fights so i think it's gonna be even
cooler just when you throw that kind of fighting
style into the series well i really appreciate
it here what is gonna be like a big emotional
conflict for the series which is uncle owen and
uh obi-wan i don't know what is left cannon and
what isn't left canon anymore these days and no
they come to like comics and such uncle owen
gets to the point he's already at this point
but we will see most likely a point where obi-wan
decides to like move far away from them where he's
like still trying to keep himself involved and
look over luke skywalker but he'll have to reach a
point and it seems like this series will end at a
moment where obi-wan will eventually go you know i
actually agree with uncle owen even though i know
he doesn't like me but i actually do get his point
and i do have to stay far away because after all
these events that have happened that takes place
in this series he does have to distance himself
but not stay too far away you know obviously stays
on tattooing i like dealing with that central
conflict of watching that decision be made where
it seems like instead of it just being uncle owen
was the one who pushed him away obi-wan himself
will probably get to a point where he realizes
he has to distance himself even more because that
shot like at the beginning with the binoculars and
watching luke skywalker seems like he's probably
living in a cave pretty close by so he can
keep a watchful eye on him ultimately he's
endangering them more by having the presence
of the force that obi-wan carries with him
that probably attracts like the inquisitors like
seeing camille here it's a river character getting
vibes that she will turn good maybe not turn good
but like in the end make some sacrifice you know
at the last minute or like some type of element
there where she goes against the inquisitors
in the end i'm excited to see the grand inquisitor
be in live action i've always liked the look and
i especially like the walking shot there the
fifth brother want to see more of him if you
watch rebels obviously you'll be pretty excited
for fifth brother i have a lot of faith in it
this looks purely cinematic in every single
way guys what'd you think about the trailer
leave your thoughts down below you can subscribe
click that bell leave a like last but not least
i want to shout out my man david gandy i
wanted to apologize we have two boxes here
that i believe are from you that have yet to be
unboxed i am sorry in a lot of ways i feel like
you are our obi one more i don't want to say
elderly but more our senior in a lot of ways
our great great great grandpa but i will
not use the word elderly our old man
who is also a wanderer a man of the martial arts
as well so you are in a lot of ways our obi-wan
looking out for us and watching over us and
i really appreciate that about you obviously
we have not shown our gratitude by unboxing said
amazing gifts from you i promise we will do that
in about six to eight months when we do it you
will be very much rewarded with a great 20 second
video of us opening and looking and going thanks
and i know that's all you need is half a smile